stasera vi parlerò di bellezza la
bellezza come strumento di cura come
strumento di miglioramento del
quotidiano l'avete visto anche nei
vostri nei vostri punti e vorrei
iniziare
con una citazione che ha accompagnato i
nostri lunghi anni di studio il mondo lo
salverà la bellezza è una frase di
dostoevskij che ha accompagnato in
qualche modo tutto il lavoro che abbiamo
fatto in questi anni ma soprattutto è
una frase che fonda in qualche modo la
nostra disciplina
la bellezza è un luogo dove ci si sente
bene come avete come avete giustamente
detto ma cosa succede quando ci si trova
a dover lavorare a dover progettare nei
luoghi più più remoti nei luoghi della
povertà della miseria della guerra della
distruzione questa parola perde
completamente di significato perde
completamente dissenso perché quello che
a prevalere è l'emergenza al bisogno per
la bellezza non c'è spazio non c'è
spazio per queste persone che vivono di
nulla che vivono nel deserto fisico
psicologico umano dell'esistenza
e allora forse questi 15 anni di lavoro
con
[Musica]
questa straordinaria in giro che si
chiama emergency che mi ha avuto il
privilegio di condividere queste
missioni nei luoghi più difficili della
terra in qualche modo ci ha insegnato
aperto un modo diverso di immaginare di
considerare la bellezza
eppure abbiamo una lunga tradizione in
italia aveva una lunga tradizione di una
bellezza civica perché già nel 1445 a
firenze
filippo brunelleschi più grande
architetto dell'epoca è sicuramente uno
dei più grandi architetti della storia
dell'umanità progettò lo spedale degli
innocenti una grandissima opera di
architettura a servizio degli ultimi
era un orfanotrofio non fanno proprio
quella famosa ruota allora in qualche
modo forse ripescando nel nostro
straordinario passato iniziamo a capire
che cosa significa questa parola quando
diventa una parola di utilità una parola
che serve una parola che trasforma il
quotidiano questa storia questa
avventura la mia avventura con emergency
inizia nel 2004 allorché come incaricati
da da gino strada di progettare il
centro di cardiochirurgia salam in sudan
e lui ci liquidò con una frase molto
semplice è lapidaria un ospedale
scandalosamente bello lo scandalo stava
su mille livelli nel portare
l'eccellenza in un luogo di guerra
di povertà portarla gratuitamente ma lo
scandalo stava anche in questa
straordinaria intuizione di considerare
la bellezza come strumento di cura
e allora qui inizia in qualche modo al
nostro viaggio inizia in iraq con un
progetto particolarmente difficile
perché ci trovavamo i campi profughi di
una guerra infinita quella della siria
quella del dell'iraq e ci siamo trovati
a progettare utilizzando i lego gli
strumenti di base con cui si
costruiscono le strutture di accoglienza
sono dei orribili contenitori che
vengono usati esclusivamente per dare
una prima assistenza per dare
quell'assistenza alle prime necessità
abbiamo voluto dimostrare che qui vedete
un opera si trova in tutti i campi e
quello che è stato il nostro progetto
abbiamo voluto dimostrare che con pochi
gesti con intelligenza con l'uso delle
proporzioni con forse con un'affettività
per questi luoghi del piantare degli
alberi questi queste cliniche sono
diventati dei luoghi in cui si sta bene
in cui le persone che soffrono della
sciagura della guerra riescono ad avere
un secondo di respiro
l'afghanistan è un'altra è stata
un'altra grandissima sfida abbiamo
lavorato nel centro di kabul centro di
chirurgia di guerra di emergency
all'ospedale storico e abbiamo dovuto
operare proprio nel luogo della
sofferenza nelle sale operatorie
nella maschera alti nella terapia
intensiva abbiamo voluto dimostrare con
questo piccolo progetto come si può
avere rispetto e dare rispetto a queste
persone che quotidianamente soffrono è
forse l'esempio più bello è luogo della
maschera alti questo luogo dove vengono
ammassate le persone per fare il primo
trial è un luogo che abbiamo voluto
attraverso questo muro rosso essere un
luogo oltre al quale doveva iniziare una
nuova storia è un luogo simbolico
un altro progetto enel sempre in
afghanistan nella valle del panshir qui
ci siamo confrontati oltre che con
questo luogo remoto e lontano da tutti e
da tutto col tema della maternità
maternità in afghanistan non rappresenta
la gioia la felicità del nuovo arrivato
a questo mondo perché il mondo che vivrà
questo bambino è un luogo di soffermando
di sofferenza di guerra e allora con
questo progetto che come vedete un
progetto estremamente semplice un
edificio a un piano con grande tetto
abbiamo voluto attraverso un lavoro con
la fisiognomica un lavoro con questo
gioco delle finestre che voleva ispirato
proprio al gioco dei bambini con questo
zig zag del tetto con il porsi di questo
edificio in modo armonioso con il
paesaggio abbiamo voluto dimostrare che
attraverso piccoli gesti si può
costruire un luogo che accoglie le
persone che arrivano a questo mondo e
anche attraverso
piccoli gesti all'interno il dipingere
in modo asimmetrico il soffitto da a
questi spazi vitalità e possibilità di
immaginare dentro questi luoghi un
futuro un altro progetto sempre legato
all'infanzia nel darfur non avevamo già
lavorato nel 2004 durante la guerra ci
siamo tornati alla fine diciamo
ufficiale la guerra per progettare
questa clinica pediatrica nel cuore
della capitale del sud darfur e qui
abbiamo voluto dimostrare come con
questo edificio si poteva dare un
messaggio diverso alle persone che dopo
anni di guerra stavano cercando di
immaginare un futuro e l'abbiamo fatto
ancora sempre con piccoli gesti l'uso
del colore è uno strumento straordinario
perché costa poco perché dobbiamo
sfatare il mito che la bellezza costa le
proporzioni non costano i colori non
costano la qualità degli spazi non costa
e con questi ospedali che si pongono in
modo umile in modo inclusivo in questi
in questi luoghi
abbiamo dimostrato che si può fare si
può fare a partire proprio da un modo di
pensare l'architettura come servizio
come servizio alla società non come
un'attività fine a se stessa
un altro elemento fondativo dei nostri
progetti e il verde il verde piantare un
albero è una è un atto che dà
immediatamente speranza e immaginazione
verso il futuro
in questo caso la clinica è stata
disegnata completamente intorno a questo
straordinario all
ma questi ragionamenti in realtà fatti
in questi luoghi lontani sono gli stessi
ragionamenti che noi abbiamo fatto in
italia
accompagnando le persone che arrivano
sofferenti nel nostro paese
qui siamo a ponticelli a napoli in un
quartiere difficilissimo è un questo è
un parco dove le persone fanno jogging
fuori dal parco perché all'interno del
parco è troppo pericoloso come vedete
questo come abbiamo trovato la clinica
la clinica questa su questo ospedale
in questo edificio è la trasformazione
di questo edificio ha seguito le stesse
regole creare uno spazio piantare un
albero costruire un luogo che desse idea
queste persone che venivano accolte con
la pari con pari dignità rispetto a
qualunque paziente
la bellezza è una bellezza estremamente
pragmatica non ha nulla di di di diete
aereo nelle vostre domande si parlava
di una bellezza architettonica staccata
dalla realtà
questa è una bellezza che è
completamente immersa nella quotidianità
nel fatto di creare e di cercare dei
luoghi accoglienti le stesse cose le
abbiamo fatte con i mezzi che seguono i
migranti arrivati nel nostro paese che
vengono a lavorare o che cercano un
futuro nel nostro paese e questo è un
progetto cui noi teniamo moltissimo
perché forse il progetto che abbiamo
realizzato nel luogo più estremo in
sudan nel mezzo del deserto dove erano
stati ammassati più di 300mila profughi
provenienti da tutte le guerre che hanno
assillato questo questo paese è un luogo
desertico sia dal punti di vista fisico
ma anche dal punto di vista sociale
dal punto di vista morale perché queste
persone non hanno futuro
e allora abbiamo pensato che l'unico
futuro che noi può se potevamo dare era
far sognare queste persone l'abbiamo
fatto creando un giardino e qui vedete
di nuovo la bellezza è una bellezza
molto strumentale una bellezza molto
pragmatica siamo riusciti a realizzarlo
anche grazie al fatto che abbiamo
costruito un sistema di depurazione
delle acque reflue che ci permetteva
anche nel deserto di poter irrigare il
giardino questo gesto
rappresenta perfettamente lo scandalo di
cui parlava gino strada
nel mezzo del deserto costruire un
giardino e questo rappresenta un vero
gesto di bellezza perché in qualche modo
ha cambiato la vita di queste persone e
soprattutto dei bambini che frequentano
questa clinica e un edificio molto
pragmatico molto molto efficiente eppure
questi alberi che stanno crescendo che
stanno creando l'unico giardino l'unico
parco di tutta questa immensa zona
rappresenta un messaggio e
l'architettura attraverso gli oggetti di
cui è fatta l'architettura tra cui anche
la natura diventa uno strumento parlante
questi giardini che nascono anche
all'interno ancora l'elemento albero
dentro l'edificio come elemento
fondativo sono gli unici luoghi pensati
per dare la possibilità ai bambini di
giocare di beneficiare e di gioire di un
prato verde che per loro è il gioco più
straordinario che possono immaginare
e tornando alla frase iniziale il mondo
lo salverà la bellezza non lo sappiamo
se il mondo verrà salvato dalla bellezza
sicuramente lavorando cercando la
bellezza anche nei luoghi più remoti
cercandola con difficoltà con serietà è
possibile immaginare un mondo diverso
del resto questa frase nella sua
versione russa la versione originale già
in qualche modo raccoglie e nasconde la
risposta perché mondo in russo si dice
mir
emir significa sia mondo che pace e
allora in qualche modo forse
dostoevskij ci ha dato la risposta forse
in questo momento in cui si continua a
parlare di guerra forse iniziare a
parlare di finire qualunque guerra può
essere l'unico atto di bellezza che si
può fare in questo momento non saprei
non sappiamo se la bellezza salverà il
mondo però sicuramente lo rende migliore
grazie
[Applauso]